Speaker 1: I'm told Snake from Moscow has fixed
their mike. Let's try it once more. Snake,
please. Are you with us from Moscow?
Speaker 6: Hi. Can you hear me now?
Speaker 1: Yes, Snake. Welcome.
Speaker 6: Hi. Thank you for taking my call. I
guess my question would be a lot more theoretical
rather than pertaining to particular issues.
But there is actually a debate among liberal
Russian elites or a general antiwar population
on the purpose and value of nonviolent protests
when Russia has engaged in an attempt to destroy
Ukrainian statehood. And so the anti-war protests,
which are peaceful, usually manifest themselves as
graffiti is writing on cash, etc., trying to
distribute anti-war messaging without getting
into any type of violent or physical
altercation with anybody or anything.
So my question to you is, do you think there is
any value or purpose in nonviolent measures in
a time which is essentially war enacted
by our government against other people?
Speaker 1: This is a really great
question because at some point, you know,
all of us who as a principle are against violence.
Sometimes we get to a point where we say,
well, we're trying to protest horribly
violent acts like the invasion of Ukraine
with signs and writing on dollar bills. And
it just doesn't. If I'm hearing you correctly,
Snake, you're saying it does. Is it really going
to achieve anything? Is it is it is it enough?
Speaker 6: Mm hmm. Yeah, this that's this
is nothing in comparison to state propaganda
and therefore is useless and doesn't exist. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I mean, I am I am sympathetic to that
question. And where I come down is
and maybe I'm naive or idealistic,
I just don't know that the random people on the
street getting violent is actually going to have
the effect on the policy that maybe we would
like it to. Compared to crippling sanctions,
government saying we are not going to allow
this or it's just hard for me to imagine it,
you know, to some degree, snake. It's like
when these people say if the Jews had handguns,
World War Two wouldn't have happened. And
every historian that has looked at it says
that's just not true. So I understand the
instinct, but I wonder how fact, how based
in reality, the idea is. I just don't know.
Speaker 6: Thank you. And if I can,
my second question is going to be slightly more
practical. How do you think we can build bridges
between populations that are not existing in the
same reality in the United States? It seems to me
like anybody more direct versus Trumpist slash
MAGA hat people in Russia, it's this so-called
Viking youth who are Soviet era ideologues
versus more younger liberal or just plain,
more moderate population of Russia. Do you think
it is even possible to build bridges between such
groups of people who don't seem to align anywhere?
Speaker 1: So I think it's possible. Here's the
answer. At the at the individual level, every
expert I've spoken to says the way you build
those bridges is you have to just start with
what we agree on. And sometimes it's very little,
but there's usually some agreement. Do we agree
that we prefer solutions without violence?
Yes. Okay. Let's use that and then see
where we get to a point of disagreement.
This is a long, arduous, time consuming process
at the mass scale level. How do we deprogram
people who won't even accept basic facts? I don't
have the answer to that, unfortunately.
Speaker 6: Okay. Thank you very
much for taking my question.
Speaker 1: So before you go,
you're calling from Russia?
Speaker 6: Yeah, from Moscow.
Speaker 1: And so what is the would
you say the general sentiment there
is that people like the invasion of Ukraine
or people are against the invasion of Ukraine?
Speaker 6: I have to say that I will have a
certain Moscow liberal bias because that's
the area where I was raised and my family has
always been critical of the government. There is
not a single person in my immediate circles that
are fans of this government. Okay. But I will say
that's just from my own personal experience,
just looking at cars or driving or parking
anywhere. I don't see a single Z sign. There is
no single, I would say, personal initiative to
install anything that is commemorative to this
war. All I've seen is a state council local
efforts which are sponsored from the state, from
the federal budget to try and convince people to
engage in such practices and some type of coercion
that's happening, for example, in kindergartens.
Oftentimes, parents discover that the school trip
or the kindergarten trip they send their children
to was actually a sort of patriotic event because
they then later find pictures of the children
posed in the letter Z on social media.
Speaker 1: That's the patriotic education
Trump keeps talking about. Now, listen,
do you feel safe expressing your views,
antagonistic to the government?
Speaker 6: On here. Yes. Okay. Over
at my university, I've already sort of spoken
myself into 15 years of prison. If anybody would,
like, dig deep anywhere around
me. So this is just a weird spaces
that I know that if anybody looked at me or
what I have been writing, what I've been saying,
it is quite possible that I will face some sort
of fine or maybe even jail time after all. That
person was arrested yesterday for walking out with
a printout of Russian constitution on the streets,
and it didn't work here again. And there are
unfortunately, I'm also, you know, like a liberal,
I'm a college professor. So if any of my students
decide that they don't like me, they can write a
letter to less than the committee, which is like a
prosecutor's office of Russia. And I will be gone.
Speaker 1: So.
Speaker 6: But on the other hand, unfortunately,
my family has had the same experience since
1930s. So it's not like we're inexperienced
in this particular situation. So it's
Russia. It's just weird and I don't like it.
Speaker 1: Well, stay safe,
Snake. And how how upset were
you by the closure of McDonald's in Russia?
Speaker 6: Actually, there is a lot of
working McDonald's spots. Well, I yeah, I
visited Kazan, which is a city in Tatarstan,
a republic within Russia. And they have
plenty working McDonald's. I think all of
them McDonald's is located at airports, are
working as well. Wow. I think franchisees
are still open while those that were commanded
by U.S. headquarters. So they have all closed.
Speaker 1: I see. I see. All right. Well, Snake,
thank you for the call. And stay safe there.
Speaker 6: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. There is snake
from Moscow and that will do it for today. We'll
take a quick break. We will take calls again.